california is known worldwide for its
walnuts producing 720 000 tons last year
alone
but as elizabeth cling from our
sacramento station kovr reports some
growers are giving up on the classic
california crop
branch by branch
acre by acre
walnut trees in place for more than a
decade at bullseye farms are now
destroyed we farm a little over a
thousand acres of walnuts and we're
removing about 500 orchard manager nick
edsel says the decision wasn't easy it
took seven years just to get these trees
big enough to produce a crop the walnuts
on these trees are just starting to form
but they won't be here long enough to
mature these are next in line to be
knocked over and dried and then sent on
to the wood chipper
in the past the biggest problem was
water it's become probably our third or
fourth worry
at the moment bill carrier with the
california walnut commission says
despite high demand for walnuts
worldwide right now california can't
deliver our number one problem is the
shipping issue definitely walnuts have a
short shelf life compared to many
commodities so it's a race against the
clock to get them loaded onto cargo
ships and sent to consumers overseas so
typical route for a ship is to come over
from china to long beach l.a load
something there and unload all their
cargo iphones and whatever else it's
bringing
and then pick up some things in long
beach then head up to oakland but right
now many ships are skipping the port of
oakland all together and heading back to
china empty so why is that prices to
bring products from china to the u.s are
soaring up to 20 thousand dollars a
container for a trip that takes about a
week but a trip to take walnuts from
california to europe may only pay a
fraction of that and require a month or
more of travel if i order a shipping
line i get the economics of it this
month both california senators joined ag
groups across the state in calling for a
summit to address the shipping crisis
saying they are quote deeply concerned
that u.s agricultural producers are
unable to secure containers to export
their products
in the meantime edsel says prices for
walnuts have plummeted and bullseye
farms can't afford to wait if we thought
that the market would recover we would
leave the walnuts in and try to just
minimize inputs for a little bit but
instead these orchards will soon be
replaced with rows of tomatoes for now a
far more reliable crop for cbs saturday
morning elizabeth cling sacramento
the water issue is understandable but in
looking this up china and the u.s
produce the most walnuts if the u.s
slows that production and then you're
looking for china to import now you have
the supply chain yes again and then
after that it's the eu ukraine and chile
that are producing so
not that you're worried about a shortage
at this point of walnuts but it's
interesting when we're getting rid of
manufacturing of something or the growth
of something here you did a deep dive on
wall yeah that was curious because i was
wondering yeah no it's interesting i
didn't know china was the top producer
yeah and we all like tomatoes nothing
wrong with replacing them with tomatoes
but but when you have a classic staple
like that that yeah but the tomatoes
take a lot of water too have you ever
tried growing up then the walnut i have
tried them no almonds are on the list
too well